Learner A4: السلام عليكم
Learner A4: الو.
Learner A6: وعليكم السلام ورحمة الله.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A4: يا شباب عاملين.
Learner A6: بخير؟ الحمد لله.
Learner A4: مظبوط.
Learner A4: معلش أنا داخل من أكاونت ثاني عالموبايل.
Learner A6: ولا يهمك أكيد.
Learner A4: الدنيا.
Learner A4: ما شايلهم.
Learner A4: ادينا معكوسة.
Learner A6: وآخر حاجة وصلت لها اللي بعتهالك يعني يعتبر عملت الحاجات المطلوبة.
Learner A6: بصراحة، أنا مش عايز احط ميوزك بصراحة في انتروا انا اعمل على بي تي ار.
Learner A6: إنما خليته دلوقتي ما بيبدأش من الأول تمام.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A4: أنت أنت أخدت قادة لان انا بعد ما انا بعتلكوا الرسالة عملت قضيت ثانية.
Learner A6: أنا أنا لما أخدتها كنت أعمل لسا أوديت بدقيقتين.
Learner A4: اللي هو في ال وفي كل حاجة صح؟ من خلال انت بس.
Learner A6: ثواني معلش اعملها تاني من عندي يعني.
Learner A4: لو ينفع لأن أنا فاكر ان انا اشتغلت في التي تي اس.
Learner A6: أوكي
Learner A6: ماشي ديت فيتشر أول ماشي تقريبا فعلا حصل عندك أبديت.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A6: ماشي
Learner A6: أند ميرسي
Learner A6: فرنج.
Learner A6: ، ماشي
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: ما معاك.
Learner A6: ماشي مفروض كده إني.
Learner A4: تمام في اختلاف كبير أو أنا غيرت حاجات في الكلام.
Learner A6: من.
Learner A4: بقدمه.
Learner A6: ثواني كده أجرب أطلع حاجة من كويس الدنيا عاملة ازاي.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Learner A6: خليه يشرح
Learner A6: يعني شرح البر فرنج
Learner A6: ماشي استنى عشان بياخد شوية وقت عشان يطلع النتيجة فا.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: هو أنا جربت. وبعدها كنت شغال. تمام بصنعة. أنا مش عارف انت كنت غيرت في
Learner A6: هو أنا اللي غيرت فيه مش كتير يعني أنا كل غيرت فيه بس هو حوار الصوت ده عشان كان في أول سلايد عندي بيفضل قاعد شوية ما بيتكلمش يفضل قاعد ما بيعملش أي حاجة يفضل قاعد كتير.
Learner A4: طب إنت عايز تحط.
Learner A6: بصراحة يا سباني أنا يعني مستحق.
Learner A4: رمى.
Learner A6: بصراحة يعني.
Learner A4: حسيت.
Learner A6: أنا مش عارف يعني
Learner A6: أحط أي حاجة أني شايفني لو ممكن أحط أي صوت عادي بس اللي هو عايز حاجة ممكن يستخدموها لو بالذات اللي استخدموها بعد كده فمش عارف.
Learner A4: أم
Learner A4: ماشي احنا.
Learner A6: مني عموما 3 حاجات
Learner A6: في حاجة منهم أنا مش فاهم بالزبط يعني المفروض أعمل فيها اللي هي بتقولك الإتش تي ام ال
Learner A6: أنا مش فاهم يعني بالظبط يعني فين لهو
Learner A6: أول حاجة الإتش دي ام ان هانسمينت المفروض أحسن ال
Learner A6: لا هو المفروض 3 حاجات هو حوار في البداية أنا ده عملته خلاص يعني ده تمام
Learner A6: اس دي هو تقريبا اللي لسه برضو
Learner A6: أنا ما أعرفش أنت تندل ازاي بس أنا باخد بالظبط اللي بيطلع من عندي و
Learner A6: وعامل زي ما أنت ما قلت إن هو ده احسن فناني بس يعني.
Learner A4: المفروض إن هو لو انت بدأت حتى وإنت بترندر عملت أسيت وكده فال إيجن بتاع عمر كدا مش بيشتغل.
Learner A6: أم فهمت.
Learner A4: وعمر صح مش عارف انت خدت بالك ولا بس هم الأرز اللي بتطلع اللي هي بتاعت فلونيشن ده.
Learner A6: وأنا.
Learner A4: هتفكسوا.
Learner A4: إذا.
Learner A4: مش إحنا كنا وقت كنا قلنا هنستخدم اللي هو.
Learner A4: مش سامع إيه معلش أنا مش سامع.
Learner A4: أنت وأنت بالجنرالية إزاي.
Learner A4: بيطلعي.
Learner A4: بعد بعد الهو هو اللي الدنيا دي علشان.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: صح.
Learner A4: ده صح.
Learner A4: ماشي ما أنا مكنتش سامعها بس.
Learner A4: بس فهو دي المفروض بقى خلاص انت تشيلها تشتغل دي الوقت فأنت مش محتاج كولونيشن.
Learner A4: وأنا.
Learner A4: أو شوفي أبروتش يعني بس هو اللي المفروض.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A4: كم من الزمن.
Learner A6: وأنا شايبه حاليا بس ترامب.
Learner A4: وانتو جادين ولا متهيألي.
Learner A6: لا، لا، أنا بستني.
Learner A4: تسمع فيها حاجة.
Learner A6: لا، لا، ما طيرتش.
Learner A4: الهدف في الآخر والله.
Learner A6: وحددوا دلوقتي الميعاد بتاع ال بريزنتيشن والكلام ده لسا ما فيش أي حاجة.
Learner A4: مارس المفروض انهم حيعرفوا بكرة أصلا هو يبقى فيزيكل ولا.
Learner A6: طيب حلو هو لو فيزيكال هيبقى فين والله ما اعرفش.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A4: ما يعملوش في وقت أنا عندي امتحان يوم 25 يوم 29.
Learner A4: هو المفروض اللي هو يبقى في نص تمانية.
Learner A4: يعني يعني كمان أنا اسبوع او اسبوعين.
Learner A4: يعني في الأغلب هيبقى في الأسبوع اللي جاي بقى.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: المفروض خلصت السكريبت ده لسته هنا في البيت والمفروض.
Learner A6: ماشي.
Learner A4: وخلصت البريزنتيشن بعنك.
Learner A6: بسيطة بإذن الله.
Learner A4: ما شاء الله بسيطة عايزين بس حنخلص البطاقة ده عشان عايزين نغير في ال في ديمو فيديو لل للوباء.
Learner A6: أنا مستني دلوقتي هي تقريبا المشكلة بس اللي بتظهر حاليا الأسس بيقعد يقول لي لأنا كنت عايز أسأله.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A4: عشان كولوني بتبعت ريكوستات كتيرة لكل فري فا.
Learner A6: نافع.
Learner A4: بالضبط.
Learner A6: شوية حاجات طالعة تمام.
Learner A4: بالزبط كده.
Learner A6: إمم أهلا وسهلا إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: أصل
Learner A4: أورب.
Learner A6: يعني بس فعلا المشكلة إنه بياخد وقت كتير قوي ما.
Learner A4: المناعة. الوضع بقى صعب ياخي.
Learner A6: الفكرة في حاجة أنا مش عارف هل الويس بريكس ده إحنا محتاجينه.
Learner A4: أو لويس فريكس كان بيعمل.
Learner A6: كان بيجيب الكلام الصوت مع حاجة بس.
Learner A4: ، لا محتاجينو.
Learner A6: إمم
Learner A6: شو دخل عالأسد حاليا هون.
Learner A4: نيوت علشان المفروض انزل.
Learner A6: أكيد.
Learner A4: السلام عليكم الو.
Learner A4: أيوه.
Learner A6: وعليكم السلام.
Learner A4: صعب جدا.
Learner A4: يعيشك.
Learner A6: هو طلعها طلع دلوقتي هو دقيقة.
Learner A4: جيسي.
Learner A6: أبعتها على جروب ولا أنا أعملها شيء بالأول دلوقتي.
Learner A4: الجزئية اللي انت عدلت عليها ولا عدل على حاجة ثانية ولا الدنيا.
Learner A6: لا، لا، تمام هو ما طلعش أي مشكلة ولا أي حاجة كل الشهر تمام يعني أعتقد إنت اللي إنت عملته إنه بدأ يزود في السكريبت فبيتكلم أكثر حاليا. تفاصيل أكتر، صح؟
Learner A4: ، لا، أنا زودت كل حاجة غيرت طريقة الشرح بتاعت الفيديو، وبعدين بدي أسألك.
Learner A6: 3 دقائق فيعني أعتقد ده كويس جدا يعني.
Learner A4: ما أنا بعته لفرح فرح قالت عليه تحفة
Learner A4: بس هي لسا عايزه بس السكريبت وعايزة،
Learner A4: فالمفروض مش عارف كان المفروض اللي هو يخش ال ما دخلش
Learner A4: سواء كان بيسأل يعني على حاجات ان شاء الله اليوم يكونوا قد خلصوا
Learner A4: ان شاء الله عمر من ايدو حاجة.
Learner A6: صحيح؟
Learner A4: هندسة.
Learner A4: أنا كل النظارة.
Learner A4: ما بس كلنا نعمل.
Learner A6: حاليا كمان عندي تمام البرنش عندي مزبوط وكله تمام.
Learner A4: انت شغال على ني برنج.
Learner A6: اللي هو اسمه اسامة فاينل أسيدز.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A6: اللي تعدل بالزبط بص وأنا كنت معدل الحاجات دي كانت بتعتك. أنت معدل.
Learner A4: ، الحاجات دي انا ما كنتش عايز اعدلها بس وانا بعمل فاينل كويست لقيت كوبايل للحاجات دي.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: فدخلت شفت هل ليها لازمة لها؟ لازمة فعدلتها.
Learner A6: أنا اللي معدل فيه يعتبر في الإم بي فور ريندر والاندر كستم بتاعي وال تيست برينت فور ده تقريبا للبي تيست يعني بس.
Learner A4: حلو.
Learner A6: وإيه تاني وبس وقبلها كنت أعملك ميرش برضه لل اللي هو الصبح.
Learner A4: عبد.
Learner A6: في الموديل كونفيج وكده
Learner A6: بس ما عدلتش كتير بقى يعني كانت كلها بس مشكلة الموديلز عشان حوار ده بس انت كنت بتقول هي مع ولا.
Learner A4: في وجه.
Learner A6: بس الباقي كله تمام يعني أنا دلوقتي هو وكده تمام عشان لما بعمل حاجة بتاع الشوبيز.
Learner A4: حتى مش لازم ترفعها عادي.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A6: يعني الباقي تمام يعني فهو دلوقتي ان شاء الله البرنش دوة أبديت بآخر حاجات عملتها وآخر حاجات انا عملتها.
Learner A4: الو تمام ماشي.
Learner A6: شير آيس كريم شاليس كريم للحاجة اللي طلعت ولا.
Learner A4: ماشي عادي ما فيش مشكلة عمر انت عرفت ترن الدنيا عندك تمام الباج بالفرنب.
Learner A4: الله الحاجات اللي انت لسه سمعتها اليوم كنت لسه حقرا.
Learner A6: ميشي.
Learner A4: عندي مشكلة في حتة المرجة دي فكنت بحل.
Learner A4: إمم جيت.
Learner A6: الأول.
Learner A4: يا ريت برانسي زي ما انت قلت لي كوفي.
Learner A4: فلاش.
Learner A6: طبعا الصوت مش ظابط قوي هنا عشان بيزبط أكتر في الفيديو لما إنت عمله.
Learner A3: صحيح؟
Learner A6: أنا مش جايب الصوت معلش قصير ولا هو.
Learner A4: ويعني صوتها مش أحلى حاجة برضه.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A4: عيش الغوطة.
Learner A6: قوي.
Learner A4: على فكرة إن الفيديو اللي بيطلع في الفيديو لما إنت بتنزله غير الموجود على.
Learner A6: بيغروا تماما.
Learner A4: غير تماما.
Learner A6: أحسن كتير.
Learner A4: وتحسها تتكلم بروح كده تحس في بني آدم.
Learner A6: أيوة.
Learner A4: اللي معك.
Learner A6: بقولك أحسن كتير.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A6: وبقلك وعلى فكرة هنا الضابط أكثر أساسا يعني يبص الإنتروب بيقعد ثانيتين ويبدأ على طول بتتكلم على طول عكس التاني إنت تحس إن إنت مش فاهم.
Learner A3: حوار.
Learner A6: الفيديو.
Learner A3: انتو اللي كنت عايزاه دا.
Learner A4: هو في حد دخل جديد، صح.
Learner A3: حطيت حوار اللي هي عايزاه.
Learner A4: فينك يا عم وحشتني.
Learner A3: أكثر لاعب.
Learner A4: حبيبي.
Learner A3: 1,000.
Learner A3: انا بس مش اقدر ارخم عليك بحاول أشتغل بصمت لكي سافرت او لا اصلا.
Learner A4: أنا متجه حاليا.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A3: تسلم بالسلامة.
Learner A6: إجا ربنا معك.
Learner A4: يا.
Learner A3: انا اشتغلت مبارح مع عمر هكذا عرفت منه. حاجات كنت محتاج اعرفها.
Learner A4: 1,000.
Learner A3: وانت جيت متأخر فلو برضو لم رضيتش غيرك قلت.
Learner A4: ربنا نائم نايم امبارح الساعة 7 الصبح
Learner A4: النهاردة الساعة احداشر بضربه بجزمة والله.
Learner A3: الله.
Learner A6: لك.
Learner A3: اهم حاجة توصل بالسلامة واهم حاجة الشغل يكون خالص لما توصل عشان لو انت مثلا تعيش.
Learner A4: أنا خلصت ال سكريبت بس.
Learner A3: ما هو الكلام الذي اراه جيد جدا؟
Learner A4: أنت لو تاخذ بالك برضه.
Learner A6: كل نص يعتبر.
Learner A3: غلط.
Learner A6: ال.
Learner A6: ما هي.
Learner A4: أنا عملتها على على.
Learner A3: غيرت في.
Learner A4: أيوا غيرت في كل حاجة غيرت في.
Learner A3: عشتو عشت.
Learner A3: أنا شغال.
Learner A4: فرنسا.
Learner A3: إن.
Learner A4: ربع سنين والله.
Learner A3: الشغلانة. دي ما تسببتش.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: فيليب.
Learner A4: إنت.
Learner A3: على طول يبقى عندنا الجديد على طول.
Learner A4: ما أنا عملت برانش ثاني عشان الناس تعرف تميز
Learner A4: تبرمت بإسم ال السكريبت إن هانسبيلت على.
Learner A3: المواجهة.
Learner A4: يعني حاصل.
Learner A6: أنا أخدت دلوقتي برانش بتاعه نفسه اللي هو آخر برانش خالص
Learner A6: واشتغلت على عندي كنت شغال انا في البرنجامة. فاينل أسيست
Learner A6: البرنش ده حاليا عليه كل حاجة عمر عملها.
Learner A3: عبد.
Learner A6: نعم.
Learner A3: ببعض لو عدنا نشتغل نشتغل على فاينل فيرش.
Learner A6: أعمله دلوقتي هو تقريبا نفس الحاجات اللي هو باعتها زيادة.
Learner A3: ليه طيب عشان الموضوع يبقى.
Learner A4: هو أنا.
Learner A6: أنا خايفة جدا بالمية بصراحة.
Learner A3: اها.
Learner A4: أنا بصراحة جاتني عملت بوش.
Learner A6: أنا مش عارف إذا أنا.
Learner A4: مين.
Learner A6: ما حدش.
Learner A4: جابنا أصل ببص على البرانج بتاع مين برانس.
Learner A6: أوف.
Learner A4: خلاص فقمت رايحة قبل ما يرجع المينو فش.
Learner A3: 1,000,000.
Learner A4: بالضبط.
Learner A3: نوع معين.
Learner A6: أنا ممكن عموما لو عايزين أبش لو انت عملت بوش دلوقت اعمل على طول.
Learner A3: يا باش أعمل ميرسي.
Learner A6: كده وحيبقى يعني هو عليه زي ما قلتلكو الحاجات بتاعتي كلها خلاص وحاجة.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A4: ما استغربت.
Learner A3: انا قضيت ونشتغل بس شغل ثاني.
Learner A4: هو في الشارع.
Learner A6: الهيكل.
Learner A3: الأولانية والشغل الباقي في ال صح كده.
Learner A4: الشغل. وهنلعب شوية في.
Learner A3: عشت انا كنت بسأل اسامة انت عملت موضوع المزيكا اللي هي كانت عايزاه دا الستاتيك بايل.
Learner A6: بصراحة.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: إنه.
Learner A4: عملت.
Learner A6: العربي.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A3: يعني ما إيه.
Learner A6: ما قبل.
Learner A3: هذا.
Learner A6: لا، أنا بصراحة، الموضوع فعملته عبيدي يعني المشكلة إنت دخلت قعدت أسأل من غيرها قالت يا حبيبي ما ينفعش.
Learner A4: يا حرام.
Learner A6: أكثر منه.
Learner A4: الليل.
Learner A6: يا بيشا.
Learner A3: بس ماشي ماشي.
Learner A6: اللي هو كانوا طالبينو اللي هو فعلا بيبدأ في الإنتروا بيسكب على طول يبص.
Learner A4: بص هو عامة إحنا ممكن نعمل.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: يعني يبقى في مثلا صوت ولا صوتين بس اللي هو إيه اللوجو يتحرك مثلا كده يعني.
Learner A6: دي ممكن.
Learner A4: هو الفكرة بسيطة.
Learner A6: دش وفي بالفعل حطينلي خلاص انترب ميوزي يعني انت شايف أنا لو حطيت عندك هيشتغل
Learner A6: أنا الفكرة كلها أنا مش عايز أحج.
Learner A4: يا دكتور.
Learner A6: بس إنما أنت حسيتا يشتغلوا.
Learner A4: أعرف إن هو أنا صاحبكن إلعب.
Learner A3: جيد.
Learner A6: حربي مش أسمع مني.
Learner A4: أنت.
Learner A6: مستعجل من كدا.
Learner A4: يعني حتى.
Learner A6: أن.
Learner A3: معاه حوار الداوكر دا وكانو كونتينر.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: مهدي.
Learner A3: أين مهدي؟ لم أره منذ.
Learner A6: وقفت شير سكرين.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A3: ولا ستاندرد لحد.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A3: يا مرحبا.
Learner A4: أحمد منصور تقريبا.
Learner A3: المواقع.
Learner A4: علي أنا بس يعني.
Learner A3: أيه.
Learner A6: لل.
Learner A4: هو أحمد منصور تقريبا بيتنطط علي أنا بس ما اعرفش.
Learner A6: بتقعد تبعتلي قسطا بجد أخاف.
Learner A3: 1 يقول لي وصلت الى ماذا يقول لي انجز والثاني يقول نزلت.
Learner A6: سوريا.
Learner A3: اعطيني البعض لدى الذين.
Learner A4: يا.
Learner A6: منصور بجد ما تخلص الطاست.
Learner A3: عمال يعني.
Learner A6: 3 أرباع.
Learner A4: في قلبي.
Learner A6: ما خلصتش ليها.
Learner A4: متلاعبين الشباب.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A6: يا.
Learner A3: من اول يوم من قبل هم يرسلوا لي في الخلفية.
Learner A4: لسان.
Learner A3: المفروض تعمل 1 2 3 منين لا.
Learner A6: يستنق أول باسك نزلت خالص أنا فاكر إنتو قلتوا. بعتلكوا الديسكبتن صح؟
Learner A3: حاجة.
Learner A4: أنا ممكن.
Learner A6: أنا ما نزليش ديسكريبشن دخلت والله بسأله بقوله إنه كان ألريدي يا باشا والله اتبعت
Learner A6: قلي لا اطلع في الشاي يا عمي الشت ايد دشيت أول رسالة.
Learner A3: ما تشغل.
Learner A4: شغلت.
Learner A6: أنا ل 6 في البداية ما كنتش أعرف
Learner A6: أنا كنت بتكلم اللواء أنا مش فاهم هل فعلا هو بعتلي من عندي يقولي إيه عرفت إنه آجي خلاص.
Learner A3: انت.
Learner A4: ما هو الذي فهمته يعني الذي يتصرف من دماغه هم واخذوا ويصلحوها يعني
Learner A4: ويقول لي الاسبوع الفائت لم تعملها.
Learner A3: لا هو العمل كده برضه معايا في الغياب.
Learner A4: الأسبوع اللي فات لسه صاحبي إنت تعرف إن هو دخل قاللي إنت محضرتش ولا ميتين.
Learner A6: لؤل كمان.
Learner A4: قلت.
Learner A3: عمر من الأول للآخر حرفيا.
Learner A6: مش.
Learner A4: وبعد أرغيت؟ وقعدت بتكلف.
Learner A3: ساعات بتشيروا داخلين زيادة.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: إنت عارف إنه كمان بعثلي بقى يقولي 50 رسالة في الجروب أنا كنت عايز أقول له والله أنا يعني أنا مش فاكر إني بعثت غير عشان أخلي ال أنا مش عارف بعثت بس يعني ربنا يكرمك.
Learner A3: لا لا الدنيا بس عادي يعني عادي إحنا أردنا نخلص القصة دي.
Learner A6: يعني الدنيا تمام الحمد لله.
Learner A3: وده وإن دل فيدل. إن عمر ما هيقدر يعمل أي حاجة أساسا.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A3: بجد والله يعني مش اللي هو يديك تجربة كانت أول مرة أشوف موضوع إنه في حد عمل أوتوميشن لشغل بني آدمين بال إي آي وحاسس إن الدنيا. مليانة
Learner A3: مليانة بصراحة بصراحة.
Learner A4: نتكلم بجد هم يعني مثلا 80% ودي مش نسبه قليله الصراحة.
Learner A3: ماشي بس 80 في المية كثير برضه كريم.
Learner A4: يعني دخلت.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: عارف.
Learner A3: على العادي برضه لسه تصحح وترد على استفسارات بس.
Learner A4: مش كده أنا قصدي هو مثلا أولا بيتابع شوف.
Learner A3: صحيح؟
Learner A4: من بوتين يعني محمد منصور ده مسؤول عن كم.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: فكرة ما بينك وما بين حد ثاني
Learner A4: هديل حد كيف حد ذاتها بوينت البوينت التانية.
Learner A3: بس مش بالقدر.
Learner A4: هو نفسه.
Learner A3: شوي.
Learner A4: هو لا، لا، هو لسه بس هو ربنا يستر يعني عشان هو في في بتحصل حاليا كده
Learner A4: هو ألريدي خلصت يعني لكن لا يتكلموا عن ناس كتير.
Learner A3: الشغل. أيوة.
Learner A4: انت عامة كومبيوتر لما يطلع الدنيا هضموش بالجد.
Learner A3: هيبة مرعبة.
Learner A4: الديني. عجوز بجد.
Learner A3: عندهم في.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A4: الفندق.
Learner A4: إزاي ده هو أساسه تبريد أصلا.
Learner A3: ما هم مش عارفين يبردوه بالقدر الكافي
Learner A3: يسخن منهم جدا بس يعني بدأوا يطلعوا بيه شغل ده في حد ذاته مرعب.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A3: لا.
Learner A4: أنا ألريدي اشتغلت كوانتو قبل كده.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: إيه.
Learner A3: ازاي ده.
Learner A4: كان في حاجة في ال ما في
Learner A4: الحاجات اللي هم بيقدروا هم يذكروها حاليا بياخدوا داتا بتاعتهم بياخدو بياخدوا يعني اللوج أو متى داتا الترافيك الحاصل.
Learner A3: ما
Learner A4: وبيعملوا لها بيعملوا عليها بالكونتم وفي حاجات تانية يعني إنت مثلا ال اي او تي ديفايسز
Learner A4: لا تتغير لمدة مثلا 10 سنين ولا 20 سنة عمرها طويل ولايت فتمام فالسيكوريتي بتاعتها إلى حد ما
Learner A4: فهم ياتوا ويعملوا ويقول لك نحن لن نستطيع الان ان نفك او لنعرف ماذا سنعمل دكريبشن
Learner A4: فاحنا حنعمل دلوقتي هاربس للكلام دوة وهاند كريت لما كومبيوتر.
Learner A4: هو قالولك لا إحنا بوست كوانتوم كريبتوغرافي اللي هو مثل.
Learner A3: للديكريبشن.
Learner A4: هي لما يطلع كونتم كومبيوترغ تبقى هي قادرة إن هي تصب أصلا
Learner A4: طبعا شغالة بقا ميكانيزم ببنت كلب يعني و تكنولوجياس بصراحة جامدة قوي
Learner A4: بس حاسس الآن دخلتوا في حتة مش أصلا كملت.
Learner A3: بس.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A4: على الرئيس.
Learner A3: اعملوا على مين عشان نشوف الفاينل أبديت عشان اشوف كده أستاذ إسمه ده عمل إيه عندي عمر درهم عشان اشوف لو في حاجه اعملها مع عاملها مع
Learner A3: عمر خالد.
Learner A6: أنا بوش حالا.
Learner A3: بحيث ان الدنيا ما تبقاش
Learner A4: تسعتاشر.
Learner A3: 1,000,000 برمش.
Learner A4: وفي.
Learner A3: هيطلع يحط لي برنج جديد.
Learner A6: كل 1 يشتغل على برنش كل أوبج بعمله بتعمل برنش جديد.
Learner A3: تعملوا برنس جديد ويتش إز.
Learner A4: زوجي.
Learner A3: خريف موت.
Learner A4: والله أنا كنت.
Learner A6: أنا بصير ما.
Learner A3: مع بعض الدنيا دايرة على إيه الفكرة في المتسوحين هنا ما بيدخلوش معانا انت فاهم أنا بقول
Learner A6: أنا.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A6: عندي.
Learner A3: اللي بيحصل.
Learner A6: هنعمل 5 برنشات كل شوية بعمل برنش.
Learner A3: بشرى رجعة.
Learner A6: وخش على بعض.
Learner A3: المشكله ان انت الارض بيطلع من عندك يعني انت المسؤول عن يعني فاينل الايود بيطلع من عندك انت اي حاجة بتغيرها بتغير حاجة مرعبة.
Learner A6: ما ما عشان كده أنا خايف بوش عاملين والله.
Learner A3: باهي.
Learner A4: ما دي حقيقة أنا واخذ بالي.
Learner A3: أنا الدنيا كلها ضربت.
Learner A6: أيوة فكر فكر منين لما بقول أنا فاكر.
Learner A4: بالله.
Learner A6: مرعوب من مين.
Learner A3: ما شاء الله.
Learner A4: والله يا ابني انا كنت جالس في الرتب قعدت تتكلم وانا في وادي ثاني خالص بحاول اظبط الدنيا
Learner A4: يمين في شمال لحد ما الحمد الله يعني.
Learner A6: لود.
Learner A4: فكرة أنا افتكرت أساسا الولد اللي عمل كده افتكرته اللي هو عمل
Learner A4: شغال عادي يعني محدش كلمه زي الفل كنت خالص حنين يعني.
Learner A3: ربنا يستر
Learner A3: طيب يعني توكلوا على الله كده وخلونا وأنا خش برضه بتاعتكو دي لو انتو ما عملتوش الدنيا.
Learner A6: أنا أنا ببش حالا وأنا باذن الله.
Learner A3: خالص زي الفرشة عشان هم في عينها.
Learner A4: ممكن.
Learner A3: وأنا يعني بقيت الأسبوع.
Learner A6: بالزبطوا.
Learner A4: لكي الاسبوع القادم.
Learner A4: الحمد الله.
Learner A4: عمر أنت لسه معانا.
Learner A3: هو لسه في اسبوع جاي يا جماعة 4 أسابيع.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: الأسبوع الجاي عشان.
Learner A4: عند.
Learner A4: قدامه قدامه.
Learner A3: دي حاجة عادية إنت بس لما تعمل بريزنتيشنالنا على.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله يعني في خلال اليومين دول يعني.
Learner A3: عرض.
Learner A4: طبعا.
Learner A3: روح يتفسح أروح.
Learner A4: 7,000.
Learner A3: انت ترجع، انت.
Learner A4: يعني لنفسي والله حرجع.
Learner A3: شركة أمريكي.
Learner A4: 7 وحافظين.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: جميل.
Learner A3: السبت لما ترجع أو اللي هو على حد الصبح مش قصة يعني هو كده ما حدش قد.
Learner A4: ما انا بس يعني هي معضلة الحمد لله.
Learner A3: كل كل يوم ولا حاجة حتلاقيها خلصت.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A3: الكلام.
Learner A4: كلها في قبلها ب 4 ساعات ربنا يحميها أستاذة ورئيسة قسم في الزناد دي.
Learner A3: ما هو تمام.
Learner A6: إجا الواحد ما صدقوا.
Learner A4: إمم.
Learner A6: مرجمها.
Learner A4: صح؟ انتم متخرين.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: يعني سنة على فكرة يعني هي سنة وساعصلكم عادي يعني لا يوجد موضوع.
Learner A3: على حاجة يعني زي ما انت شايف كدا بتخرج مش بقى على حاجة انت زي ما انت شايف نحن خارجين عاملين ازاي اللي هو عادي عارف ان المشروع كله ممكن يخلص قبلها بأسبوع قسط يعني.
Learner A6: تعودت على كل.
Learner A3: تعودت على الزلمة.
Learner A4: حرفيا. هو نفس علي
Learner A4: من هذه الأشياء. أنا فعليا عندي برودكتات خصوصا السنة الفائتة هذه ربنا والله العظيم ربنا لا يكتبها على أحد أبدا
Learner A4: بس هو فعليا الدكاتره عندنا وضعهم صعب ووضعهم صعب جدا هناك مشكله.
Learner A3: تصدقني بكل حاجة.
Learner A4: الوضع سيء اي حقيقه.
Learner A3: بترضي كل اربع 5 اشخاص كل ترم بتروح ترضيهم مختلفين شوف كل 1 نفسه في وتحققله الامنيه اللي هو بيتمناها.
Learner A4: مع السفينة عندنا.
Learner A3: ليه.
Learner A6: أنا جامعة الكاميرا.
Learner A3: انت قلت يا اسامة.
Learner A6: الطيارة جسمنا.
Learner A3: لا والله يعني.
Learner A4: نفس.
Learner A6: عشان كدا.
Learner A3: مش نص الدفعه.
Learner A6: لا، لا، إنت خريج الصناديق.
Learner A3: لا، لا خليك بالتاكيد. انا اقول حوار حقيقي.
Learner A6: أنا عشان كدا ساكت بصراحة يعني.
Learner A6: بس خلصنا خلصنا منه.
Learner A3: انت في دكتور عندنا في القاهرة أنت مجرد دخلت وخرجت انت فعلا ما تبقاش عالدنيا غير بقى الموضوع بتاعنا بقولك لما بتتخرج
Learner A3: اكيد انت عارف اسامة الهواء محمد الرمل.
Learner A6: طب تخش لكم.
Learner A3: تحقق أماني يعني نحن نعمل مكاتب.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A3: عندنا.
Learner A4: أمريكا.
Learner A6: بيد اللي أنا مش طايقو.
Learner A4: المشكلة.
Learner A3: أمين.
Learner A4: الجامعة اللي عندنا جديدة.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: هم جايبين دكاترة شغالين مع.
Learner A3: أي حد ما عندو.
Learner A4: دفاع جوي، لا، لا، جايبين دكاترة.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: شغال في فيزا بتعليق معرفش كان بيعمل حاجات للخارجية.
Learner A4: يا له وكان بيعمل إيه.
Learner A6: بعمل جامد ده.
Learner A3: دانس.
Learner A4: هم.
Learner A3: ما.
Learner A4: بالزبط كده هو مصطفى.
Learner A4: انت فهمت انا الدفعة الثالثة أصلا يعني أنا.
Learner A3: أهلا.
Learner A4: الدفعة الثالثة لسه تقول بسم الله التخرج.
Learner A3: انت ذكرت اصلا.
Learner A4: فرنش بس يعني بصي لفيت على كل الأقسام اللي انت عايزها شوف انت عايز.
Learner A3: كمبيوتر يا راجل الله يعينك.
Learner A4: بأن.
Learner A3: جدا.
Learner A4: وعلى فكرة العميد بتاعنا اسمه مصطفى سليمان مصطفى سليمان ده في الفين واربعة كان مقدم على احدى 10 كور ولا مش عارف كود.
Learner A3: الحاجات دي.
Learner A4: انت متخيل ده كان بيدينا.
Learner A3: بإذن الله.
Learner A4: وكمبيوتر إنز.
Learner A3: واو 2,000.
Learner A4: صايم.
Learner A3: الحاجات دي كانت موجودة الفين واربعة.
Learner A4: انت متخيل.
Learner A6: بكلمة تين قليلة عليه والله.
Learner A4: حرفيا بس المشكلة يا اما تلاقيه تقيل والحمد لله ربنا يدي له عقل فتره سليمة.
Learner A3: دي المشكلة بقى ما هي دي المشكلة؟
Learner A4: يا إما تلاقيه ودماغهم سواحف 60.
Learner A3: لوحده ما انت بتروح معاه.
Learner A4: لا لازم ياخدك طبعا لازم يخدك.
Learner A3: رحلة في التسريحة.
Learner A4: ، تعال.
Learner A3: لا، لا على خير ما تقلقش.
Learner A4: الحمد والقبول والكلام ده والله الحمد لله
Learner A4: الحمد لله ربنا يعاها على خير.
Learner A3: تخصصي يا أسامة.
Learner A6: أنا تخصصية برضه.
Learner A3: إيه أخبار الدنيا في الدفعة الجديدة عشان إحنا الدفعة بتاعتنا كانت بعافية شوية.
Learner A6: الله.
Learner A3: بتدي كم كورس دلوقت.
Learner A3: أسماء بتدي كم كرسي.
Learner A6: والله أسماء دي اللهجة.
Learner A3: الملكة.
Learner A6: والله بجد، أنا كنت معاه في مشروع التخرج.
Learner A3: هذا كلام برضه.
Learner A6: والله يعني بس.
Learner A3: عدي عليك وائل طبعا.
Learner A6: وائل وائل كان.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A6: وائل تسريحة شاطرين.
Learner A3: الذي أحلى تصريح سناء.
Learner A6: لأنه.
Learner A3: إن شاء الله.
Learner A6: رحت.
Learner A3: أيمن.
Learner A3: نعم، مهو، نحن كنا نذهب للقصر لقينا.
Learner A6: من.
Learner A3: بتاعة الدكاترة.
Learner A6: بجد.
Learner A3: برضه.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A6: وجاب لنا مش عارف وحاجات ربنا.
Learner A3: وفي كافتيريا ثانيه اسمها النيل قدام القصر العيد.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A3: لا لا إحنا كنا.
Learner A6: قابله.
Learner A3: سواء كان الدكتور برضه بتاعنا في مشروع التخرج كان هو وأسماء فصباح الفولي.
Learner A6: وائل ده كفاية.
Learner A6: أنا ما قدرتش أكمل معاه الفكرة كانت صعبة اللي هو عايزها وملي مش لاقي داتا وعايزنا نشتغل طبية
Learner A6: رحنا قلنا.
Learner A3: كل اللي أنت وجهته ده اشتغلنا معاه وعملنا مشروع تخرج احنا مشروع الثاني على الكلية.
Learner A6: أم جميل جدا.
Learner A3: يعني مشروع التخرج بتاعنا الثاني على الكلية.
Learner A6: موزر ولا كان.
Learner A3: كان اسمه ولا كان اسمه
Learner A6: كان بيعمل.
Learner A3: انا لا اذكر اسم مشروع التخرج كان اسمه.
Learner A4: مصطفى. أنت عرفت تجيب ميديكال داتا.
Learner A3: اهاليزيشن.
Learner A4: طيب على غرار.
Learner A3: من أنا اللي كنت جايبها أصلا. وكنت جايبها من على هاجن فيس.
Learner A6: ولدت.
Learner A4: كان نوع الداتا.
Learner A3: سوماريزيشن.
Learner A4: داتا الداتا اللي كانت طالعة.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: ممكن ما اعرفش سيدي.
Learner A3: لا اذكر والله اسمك كوربس دعيني اقول لك اسمها. انا اذكر اسمها اسمها امي هيلث ويم آي هيلث
Learner A3: كانت ميديكال تو كومبورز انت ممكن تروح تشوف كل ما انت عايز تشوفه فيس.
Learner A4: لأنه هو في.
Learner A3: إن أنا فاكر مش أكثر.
Learner A6: داعش.
Learner A3: عدينا يعني.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A3: وقعدنا قعد يقول حاجات خيالية وقعدنا نتحرك معاه.
Learner A6: الطريق.
Learner A3: صح.
Learner A6: تشتغلوا معي.
Learner A3: هذا.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A3: سؤال علمي.
Learner A6: بتعرف نحنا ما.
Learner A3: ويجبني بعد ما تخرجنا.
Learner A6: وئام.
Learner A3: جابنا بعد ما تخرجنا ان ناخذ منه اي حاجة ولا أي حاجة ولا.
Learner A6: أساسا.
Learner A3: ولا أي عارف اللي خدنا منه شوية الليمون اللي شربناه.
Learner A6: لا.
Learner A3: وايت.
Learner A6: عارف.
Learner A3: وعنده شركة هو ببيع حلو جدا، حلو.
Learner A6: مهو أنا بقول إحنا نصبنا بصراحة إحنا عملنا يعتبر قلناله طيب يعني إنت حتدينا الشهادة كشهادة التدريب اللي هنقدمها تدريب السفلي الكلية عندنا.
Learner A3: طب حلو.
Learner A6: وخدناه من.
Learner A3: طب جامد والله ده انتوا استفدتوا جامد على كده.
Learner A6: إننا دكتور مشان أتكلم مع حضرتك.
Learner A3: مع السلامة.
Learner A6: والله عملت جواب غيرك.
Learner A3: وربنا يبره عليك اجدع مني والله العظيم أجدع من الخمسة اللي كانوا معي.
Learner A6: معرفتش. أنا كان في 1 في الدين معاه عايز كمل لوحدك أنا مش.
Learner A3: أعمل مشروع تخرجها.
Learner A3: لا، لا، رهيب رهيب رهيب يعني.
Learner A6: والدكتور.
Learner A3: 1,000.
Learner A6: اللوبي.
Learner A3: على.
Learner A6: مش عارف إيه وكده وأنا كنت متأكد بس أهم حاجة إنه في الكلية لما أنت تقابلت قلت حلو أوي عشان كنت آخذها بعدين بس أنا كنت.
Learner A3: مش هيقبلوا الشهادات. دي.
Learner A6: ما بس قدمتها واتقابلت بالفعل.
Learner A3: تنفض والله استفدت منه شيء نحن ما استفدنا منه غير شوية حاجات سخنه وانتهينا.
Learner A6: لا، لا.
Learner A3: ومسبورة الدنيا مشوارنا مشواره الدنيا وقعدنا مع ناس وإفنتات وعارف يعني بص اتنفخنا مع.
Learner A6: نخش يفنت.
Learner A3: أيوة أيوة بيبعت بيبعت لنا.
Learner A6: كمان.
Learner A3: نعم، والله رهيب جدا يعني.
Learner A6: زين.
Learner A3: درست الحمد لله انت طلعت من تحت ايدهم الحمد لله انت عديت عملت هيك.
Learner A6: الحمد لله يعني كان إيزي بصراحة مش إيزي قوي بصراحة ال تيم.
Learner A3: جيبي كان ما طبعا كده كده جيبي إيه كمان.
Learner A6: جي بي اي جيبي حاليا 3.
Learner A3: لا، لا قصدي بتاع مشروع التخرج.
Learner A6: جيب لص الحمد لله.
Learner A3: ما شاء الله.
Learner A4: مساء الخير.
Learner A3: معرض المشاريع.
Learner A6: عرض مشاريع.
Learner A4: والله مذابين.
Learner A3: ما رحتش.
Learner A6: ما بصراحة يعني.
Learner A4: أنا مع عمر بيتكلم.
Learner A3: عمر.
Learner A4: بقول لكم انتوا في بريزوريشن دلوقتي.
Learner A3: احنا
Learner A4: في مشروع التخرج يعني.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: دي.
Learner A3: يبقى خمسه على الاقل.
Learner A4: 5.
Learner A3: 5.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A3: كامل إحنا بالعافية خلوها 2.
Learner A4: أخ.
Learner A6: اتنين إحنا كنا 5.
Learner A4: لا بالعافية. هم وأنا أصلا كمان.
Learner A3: مايو.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A3: والكلام ده.
Learner A4: 2 ده مش علي انا يعني يعني ده اللائحة الجديدة بقى.
Learner A3: لكن أنا.
Learner A4: الدولي.
Learner A3: ده.
Learner A3: جامع مستحيل. أرد.
Learner A4: مش إيه.
Learner A4: ميرسي ميرسي.
Learner A4: آسف، للأسف.
Learner A4: جي يوغ.
Learner A3: اشتغل لوحدك هند وباك هند وإي آي وكل حاجة.
Learner A4: بروجاج بتاعي زي الزفت أصلا وأجلته عشان السوبر اللي كنت بخش معاها لبستني في الآخر الفكرة
Learner A4: مكنتش فكرة وحدة يعني كانت تالت أفكارهم ودخلوهم لبعض وفي الآخر.
Learner A3: حلاوة.
Learner A3: وكمان سيطروا عليكم يا لهوي.
Learner A4: لأ هو إنت اللي بتختار السوبر إنت بتروحله وهو بمزاجه يقولك إنت معاه ولا لأ ممكن في الآخر أول ما تيجي تبدأ السوبر أصلا إحنا عندنا
Learner A4: متقسم مادتين.
Learner A4: أوه.
Learner A4: هو العود.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A3: إحنا كده.
Learner A4: وهو جراد. ون بيبقى.
Learner A3: بريزنتيشنز.
Learner A4: أول 3 شبكات بس من الديكومنتيشن وبعد ذلك كله ديفيروبمنت يعني.
Learner A3: طيب يا جماعة أنا شايف إن إحنا محتاجين نقعد مع بعض يعني محتاجين.
Learner A4: نعم.
Learner A4: برأيي
Learner A3: بجد والله لازم نتعامل يوم على
Learner A3: يعني ممكن نتقابل انا كنت قلت لعمر تقريبا وعمر كان قال تمام يعني زبطوها.
Learner A4: والله يعني أنا بعد يوم 29 ما عنديش مشكلة.
Learner A3: تسعه و20 ثمانيه مش بعيد شوية نحن نكون خلصنا من زمان.
Learner A4: أنا عشان بمتحن بامتحن ساعتها يعني أنا حرفين أنا عندي.
Learner A3: فإنت منين أصلا يا عمر.
Learner A4: أنا في أكتوبر.
Learner A3: عمر أسكت يا عمر حنبقى نقعد في اكتوبر
Learner A3: لا تعملي فيها وقاعد في اكتوبر خلاص يا عمر بعد أي امتحان.
Learner A4: يعني يعني مش إيه معلش
Learner A3: هو.
Learner A4: فإنه.
Learner A3: جامعتك مش بعيدة انت قاعد في اكتوبر وهي في اكتوبر.
Learner A4: الجامعة جنب البيت.
Learner A3: لا أيوا قشطة لحتى.
Learner A4: نزل هي من كومبيوتر انتيراكشن كروس يعني والمادتين الدكاترة اوسخ من بعض
Learner A4: وإنت من سوريا أصلا.
Learner A3: شكله إيه.
Learner A4: انت ميدور
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Learner A4: وأنا كنت.
Learner A3: وانت بتشتغل قبل هيك.
Learner A4: هو إحنا عندنا عندنا من التالتة بتكمل الكلية.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: بس كملت كومبيوتر سياسي الأول بعد كده لقيت الدنيا
Learner A3: أسامة.
Learner A6: أيوة سامحك.
Learner A3: ما شاء الله.
Learner A3: لا الذي هو جامع القاهره.
Learner A6: نافع.
Learner A3: عندنا تنسيق أنت تعرف كده عمر.
Learner A3: الذي انت عايزه انت بتدخل التنسيق.
Learner A3: افهم ايش.
Learner A6: قعدت وقتها على فكرة.
Learner A4: والله بصاعت وما ينفتحش بتاع إيه.
Learner A3: انسى.
Learner A4: ما فيش حاجة تفتح ولو انتوا فاكرين مدلعين فمتهيألكوا والله بنشوفها في الأول دي يعني.
Learner A6: شو.
Learner A4: أوي.
Learner A3: الله.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A3: الطريقة يعني.
Learner A3: ، عرفت.
Learner A4: هنيئا لك.
Learner A3: انت تنصلت دلوقتي ولا روعة.
Learner A4: روعة.
Learner A3: طيب خلاص يا إما هانت إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: والله بص هو المفروض أكون متخرج من بدري بس يعني الوالد أنا كنت متأخر سنة عن الدفعة بس.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: الوالد توفى من 3 سنين.
Learner A4: الله يرحمها يارب.
Learner A4: فاضطريت فقعدت الجامعة شوية لحد ما.
Learner A3: الله يعينك والله الله يعينك لا لا ان شاء الله تتفرج بالسلامة السنة دي.
Learner A6: والله.
Learner A3: صح.
Learner A6: مبخر قلينا معاكم.
Learner A4: لأ لو سمحت لسه.
Learner A6: يعني.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: أم انت ستخش نايس ترمي ايضا او الثمر بس.
Learner A4: لا ما خلصتوش.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: ما هو اللي كنت داخل معها تكنولوجي أوكي.
Learner A4: يلا.
Learner A4: وأدخل عليهم نموذج آي نموذج.
Learner A3: وماله.
Learner A4: بالوقت.
Learner A3: فهمتوا، فهمتوا حوار حقيقي الأحلام.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله بس.
Learner A4: منورة.
Learner A4: العود.
Learner A4: الفكرة و.
Learner A4: حافل. أوكي لو احتجت او احتجت عامة كتكنولوجي.
Learner A4: حبيبي. فأنا شغال في.
Learner A4: ماشي يا ريت.
Learner A4: حبيبي.
Learner A4: ميش الوقت.
Learner A4: كملوا انتو لو في حاجة بس كلمونا يا جماعة يعني اي حد يطلع معاه أي حاجة يبعتلي الرجعة سو.
Learner A6: هو أنا.
Learner A4: ساعة. ما أنا عملت ورش وأنا عمال أحللي كانوا متين و90 دلوقتي.
Learner A6: هو.
Learner A4: ربنا.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله الماي كده تمام.
Learner A6: بإذن الله.
Learner A4: بحلمه عشان.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي كملوا أنتم عايز أنا هأطلع.
Learner A4: وانا كده خلاص النهارده عشان يعني اعرف شغلك.
Learner A3: ممكن نقفل المتينغ على كدا وخليونا نتقابل يعني.
Learner A6: بس لازم.
Learner A3: دي قعدة عايزين نقعدها مع بعضنا نقعد نتعرف على بعض أكتر عادي.
Learner A3: ستاند.
Learner A4: عليك.
Learner A3: نتعرف على بعضنا فإيش كان ممكن نزبط.
Learner A6: لأ تفضل.
Learner A3: إشت.
Learner A6: طيب بإذن الله.
Learner A3: بس.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A3: تمام مع السلامة.
Learner A6: مع السلامة.
Learner A4: خليني أسوي.